what up space fam golden here from anime
outfire and i'm back at it again to
discuss zoro one of my favorite
characters and the signs and clues
pointing to the fact that he already has
a devil fruit so make sure to stay tuned
for this one if you do enjoy these one
piece videos i want to keep them coming
you know what to do channel parakeet
within and smash that like button with
no mercy remember smashing is pirating
energy and passing is scared of roche
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on all the yonko warlords mythical zones
and much more link to that playlist is
in the description and now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all so we know zoro is very powerful
and it's true that he doesn't
necessarily need a fruit but there are
clues especially in the new arc that
zorro already has one it wouldn't be the
first time zoro having a devil fruit was
brought up even oda himself played
around with the idea before in a
question coroner he was asked if zorro
and other straw hats were to become
ability users what kind of fruits do you
think they would have eaten oda answered
he would like to see zorro with kaido's
fish fish fruit mythical type model
serio so ignoring the fact that kaido
has that fruit currently i think it's
fascinating that oda revealed he'd love
to see zorro's sword specifically with a
mythical zone devil fruit not only did
he acknowledge it's possible but even
that he'd like to see it oda obviously
wouldn't reveal zorro already having a
mythical zoned sword but dancing around
the idea here in a favorable way begs us
to explore this possibility in more
detail and yes in my view it would be
more likely that zoro's sword has the
devil fruit rather than him he's still
the user of the sword and in a way the
wielder of the fruit by extension now
what recent events made me want to
explore this idea more seriously than
ever before well to begin with i'm
fascinated with enma and the amount of
coverage and focus it got in this arc
enema is one of the 21 great great or
excellent grade swords depending on the
translation you use it is one of only
two known weapons to ever injure kaido
before the present day events of the
story the official of this translation
says enma is said to split the earth to
the bottom of hell and is one of the 21
excellent grade swords zorro is warned
that only one man has tamed enma and
that was kozuki odin this kind of
personification is also associated
specifically with zone devil fruits now
because as we found out from the five
elders recently they specifically have
wills of their own and so it's not
impossible that the gomu gomu fruit
which is actually a mythical zone was
evading them for 800 years as we proceed
enema will similarly appear to have a
will of its own we see zoro using it in
the beginning to slice off the coastline
shocking even sanji it's not an easy
blade to wheel though since it exudes
the wielder's ryo or haki on its own it
slices more than needed and although
zoro has some trouble in the beginning
he actually does better than most
wielding it since we're told a normal
swordsman would already be a mere husk
if they used it like zoro did zorro
being zorro of course accepts the
challenging sword now the interesting
thing about the name enma is that it is
the name of the king of hell in japanese
buddhist myth the judge of dead souls
this god is associated with a
dangerously difficult to control
personality another bit of trivia is
that its size was very inconsistent
since despite zoro and odin being vastly
different heights the sword looks normal
in both of their hands putting all this
together it's clear that this is no
ordinary sword and at this point already
we might assume that it has some sort of
mythical zone human human fruit model
enema or model god of the underworld
within it on a side note the whole god
or king of hell idea reflects rogers and
ray lee's relationship really well as
rayleigh too was called the dark king
while roger was the pirate king i feel
like zoro and luffy will have a very
similar dynamic as well but let's move
on because the clues and evidence don't
stop there zorro uses enma during the
fight against kaido and big mom he tells
himself he's gonna have to unleash this
enema a bit more he eventually gets an
opportunity to cut kaido with enema
during chapter 1002 page 12. kaido is
asking what's that while zoro's enema is
glowing big mom says and i quote look
out that's no ordinary sword end quote
that quote in and of itself is another
big clue that enma is special and
probably has a zoned devil fruit zorro
uses the move dragonblaze and he misses
he does cut off the horn from the
onigima skull but even if it didn't land
it's still significant it was a slash
that scared two yonko and kaido who
often doesn't avoid attacks decided he
better avoid it he also brings up how
does zoro's katana bear the presence of
odin within it here we get another
parallel to how zunisha was sensing
joyboy's presence in luffy and why did
he sense it because they had the same
devil fruit and so it's possible kaido
isn't actually sensing odin he's just
sensing the fruit within the sword that
he's come to associate with odin because
odin used it during that fight later as
zoro prepares another attack kaido asks
himself is that katana the source of the
strange haki zoro uses black rope dragon
twister attack and it actually hurts
kaido as killer excitedly points out
that zoro actually cut kaido's scales
it's also noteworthy that before he
launches this attack zorro swords aura
took the shape of a dragon during
chapter 1003 on page 10. kaido ii says
and i quote he actually cut me that
hurts i see that must be odin's sword
end quote soro cuts prometheus multiple
times so prometheus has trouble helping
big mom and then during chapter 1010
zorro tells law that what he's about to
do is the limit of his ability he tells
kaido who is saying he's going to smash
luffy's brains or heart that that's his
captain and if he wants to crush
anyone's skull he'll have to start with
zorro so epic he uses demon aura 9 sword
style asura blades drawn dead man's game
yes it's a long name but it's useful to
pay attention to zoro's attacks he uses
words like demon and asura was a class
of beings who opposed the vedic gods
like the name enma zoro plays up this
underworld demon spin for himself
through his attacks at this point kaido
and law are shocked that zoro succeeds
in cutting kaido across the chest and at
this point kaido notices that zoro is a
conqueror's hockey user as well but like
luffy who's unaware that his true fruit
is a zone zorro just says he has no idea
what kaido is talking about before he
falls to the ground kaido praises him
saying he did enough the wound will
remain with him like odin's attacks did
this shows how impressively strong zorro
with enma is enough to leave a lasting
wound on a mythical zone user one dubbed
the strongest creature wouldn't be a
shocker if zoro had the help of a
mythical zone to do it since kaido
definitely had the help of a mythical
zone to defend it and let's not forget
about how before this zorro blocked
conquest of the sea a combo attack by
big mom and kaido it was bone chilling
he saved three supernova captains by
blocking two yonko's combo attack and
still had the energy to drop a lasting
wound on kaido and then as if impressing
everyone blocking a yonko combo attack
and permanently wounding kaido wasn't
enough zorro is temporarily healed later
and goes on to fight king the yonko
commander with the highest known bounty
hilariously enough while he's fighting
king he also has the energy to promise
to kill sanji if he stops being himself
after the latter unleashes his finisher
on queen later azor was thinking he
needs to find out what race king is if
he hopes to defeat him and must starts
going off responding to hiri's shamisen
playing the sword causes zorro to scream
in pain as his arm shrivels up again
clearly this sword has a will of its own
more so than we've seen with most other
weapons in one piece in fact let me know
if you could think of any other weapons
that have shown this much will zoro
straight up tells it like he's talking
to a misbehaving pet and i quote who
gave you permission to unleash your
power enma and quote king even comments
what's wrong having an argument queen
then tells us that king is a lunarian a
monster capable of surviving in any
natural environment and even adds in the
distant past his people were known as
gods so this goes perfectly with what we
were just talking about zoro's attacks
positioned him as a demon opposing gods
and here he has to cut down in a sense a
god sorrow continues to talk to enma
telling it to wait and to stop again
like a person trying to tame their pet
when he takes advantage of the weird
situation king even says a sword's been
held back by his own sword that's a new
one again showing that it's not normal
for sores to have this much of a
personality this much of a will king as
the strongest commander of the strongest
creature in the world would have had
ample opportunity to see something like
this that is if it was just a weapon
thing and not a special devil fruit
thing zorro then goes on to treat all
his soras like his friends while king is
surprised that he'd die just to save his
sword during his flashback zorro is told
by the old man of the village aka the
master swordsmith that a sword has its
own personality a swordsman must master
it and bend it to his will so some might
assume that this is what's happening
with enma but i hope i've shown enma is
a special case and in my view it's done
things that are beyond explaining away
by saying all swords have a personality
he tells zoro in the flashback that
there was one blade he crafted when he
was a young man it was the greatest
weapon he ever made it's this position
was deadly serious just holding it in
your hand sent a shiver down your spine
so i gave that masterpiece the name of
the king who watches over hell the king
of the underworld enema and back to the
present zorro sees the aura emma's
giving off even while he's not touching
it notably he doesn't see that with the
other swords like zone devil fruits
blacksmith shimotsuki kosaburo says a
great blade can see into a person and
chooses only the swordsman who best
suits it and come on would it not be
perfect for zorro's demon theme and for
enemas underworld theme for them both to
be associated with a devil fruit zorro
concludes that enma came to him so he
could test him again this is very
reminiscent to me of how luffy's fruit
probably chose him and how yamato's
fruit probably chose her and so on zorro
says it was his strength that was
lacking rather than the sword being
wicked rather than trying to limit it
zorro allows it to drain as much hockey
as it wants asking it so odin wielded
you as though you were light as a
feather enma end quote zoro remarks if
he has to keep exuding haki like this
it'll kill him but then he says no
that's perfect we all know zoro has
never minded getting close to death
because of so much conqueror's haki
surrounding beast pirates pass out and
king remarks to zoro so you intend to be
a king then like i said new era dark
king zorro zoro uses attacks with king
of hell in the title against king
referencing enma the final one which
finishes king off for good is called
king of hell three sword serpent 103
mercy's dragon damnation afterwards
zorro says guess i might as well become
the king of hell and then has enough
energy to create another sword slash so
powerful that it sends him flying back
to the island now all of this alone
would be enough in my opinion to warrant
a zorro's sword has a devil fruit theory
or even more specifically a king of hell
devil fruit but possibly the biggest
proof comes next during chapter 1038 we
see something truly unique for one piece
we see zorro who remember took medicine
that would temporarily relieve his pain
from the yonko fight so he could fight
king but then the pain would come back
with a vengeance even worse than before
and that's not counting all the new
damage he accumulated from the king
fight so he must be as near death as you
can get and that's when it happens he
sees what looks like the grim reaper it
appears before him as zoro remarks
what's going on my body won't move no
stop it don't do it and this led to
theories oh maybe he's hallucinating and
it's brook coming to help him which
wasn't the case or maybe he's so weak
he's just completely hallucinating and
he didn't see anything which wouldn't
make much sense to me oda wouldn't throw
in something like that only to later say
it was a complete hallucination then
there's a possibility that it is the
grim reaper coming to collect zoro's
life but that wouldn't make sense either
from what we've seen in one piece there
haven't really been any real gods aside
from godly devil fruits and people so
for me the best explanation is that this
is the manifestation of enemas king of
the underworld devil fruit and perhaps
we finally see the figure because it has
finally undergone awakening just like we
didn't know luffy had the sun god fruit
until that fruit underwent awakening
this to me would explain all the
inconsistencies from why was enma so
different from other swords to what is
the grim reaper figure so let me know
your thoughts do you agree that it's
possible or even likely that oda gave
zorro's new sword a mythical zone fruit
as he himself said he'd like to do or do
you think there's another explanation
for all these crazy events surrounding
zoro this arc and if so what are your
explanations i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the matter unless proven
otherwise i honestly believe that this
theory makes the most sense but as usual
we'll have to wait and see to know for
sure but in the meantime if you did
enjoy this video and want to keep them
coming you know what to do chandler
power king within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is power king energy
and passing is scared orochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
in all the yonko warlords mythical zones
and much more link to that is in the
description also check out my video
similar to this one on why i truly
believe that blackbeard already has a
mythical zone and until next time see ya
space cowboys